whoa I'll come on Jessie you're not even
having a little fun I mean I am I mean
sure the world is in danger but this is
our chance to be heroes just don't lose
track of why we're here okay if we don't
get the order back together the weather
storm is going to eat everything that
means we need to get to magnet as soon
as freaking possible you know what
you're right we're gonna find Magnus
bring them back and he'll totally know
how to blow that thing sky-high uh dude
why does it hate us so much the minecart
hurry use something on that gas okay you
guys Jesse
like to choose
just um don't miss okay I don't want it
to hate us even more
time to move buddy let's go
you were awesome Jesse with that gas
chasing the minecart that is like the
perfect warm-up for when we get to
boomtown boomtown yeah boomtown
this is it I liked it when you in first
last time maybe you should take this one
again
just be careful okay one wrong step
look great
whoa you see that utter chaos man
Wow cactus you don't see these back home
I take it as a souvenir but I don't want
to stick it in my pants good call buddy
to all these belong to different
griefers
dude it's freaking glowy it did this
before remember at the temple yeah and
look it glows brighter when I move in
certain directions easy does it easy
maybe to the left no the right I mean
your left right I need your right whoa
whoa ding ding ding looks like that
spire is where we'll find Magnus hey
there new people you uh you said you
know where Magnus's all the griefers
here in boomtown want to find Magnus you
know well I think so you see we're
looking for him yeah we're on important
business I hope it's not to give a
fashion consultation cuz sheesh what's
going on
nor found some noobs the thingy that can
find Magnus Jesse bunch of scavengers
this drop is mine how about you help us
huh I promise it's to help save the
world yeah sounds complicated I prefer
you're just handing over the thingy Wow
get back you're gonna oh mighty Magnus I
have for you this offering
but they go in the same way they're
working together
this is just how we do it in boomtown
which one took the amulet
the thief is mine you take the one with
the fishing poles got it hey no one's
the best time of year is to visit
boomtown let me guess fall no later
dingus in one way out of the pit
Axl Jessie there you are so I totally
cornered that fissure dude and they were
all scared and stuff where is the amulet
stop right there how about no these
bricks will take forever to punch
through luckily I think I found us a
punch free entrance
sorry guys but I've been trying to find
Magnus for way too long for you to stop
me now Oh Jessie look up way too close
you know what you remind me of this song
I had stuck in my head ones I just
couldn't get it to go away yeah oh man
okay little amulet show me the way of
course not sure what I'll do when I get
there but thats future NORs problem I
bet ah give it back this is more
important than you know Oh
oh ha nice try tell you about teamwork
what but I'm the one who said we should
work together no you didn't give me that
got it I actually got it quick flush him
out
Axl Magnus's summer in that building
above us he's got to be close then quick
toss me the amulet you're surrounded by
creepers are gonna tear you apart well